eu já vim apresentar sobre um assunto
muito importante no mundo todo que é a
importância de deficientes intelectuais
na sociedade e no mercado de trabalho
primeiramente eu vou começar falando que
ele tem vários caminhos para o futuro
tanto para pessoas que têm deficiência
intelectual ou não
todos nós temos estoques se concretizar
somos todos iguais em um único caminho é
sempre subir e se tornar destaque por um
mundo mais justo colorido e feliz
respeitando e unidos em suas diferenças
juntos por um futuro feliz em qualquer
época ou seja papéis do bt até o idoso
quero que esse vídeo porque pelo menos
pra mim transmitir uma imagem de muita
alegria mas ao mesmo tempo passe não sei
se vocês entendem é sempre vai existir
um caminho repleto de paz e esperanças
sem diferenças
se você quiser se concientizar de tudo
isso de tudo isso comece hoje sempre
amando respeitando e lembrando e
pensando sempre do próximo
essa serra gostei muito porque ela diz
assim ajude os outros e se desenvolverem
quando você transforma positivamente a
vida de outra pessoa da nossa própria
vida uma bênção ou seja quando você
transforma néel você pode até mesmo
ajudar quando você ajuda positivamente a
vida de outra pessoa
eu sei que se fala obrigada
hoje existem várias campanhas como essa
aqui que eu achei bem interessante que
diz assim autismo não é uma tragédia e
sim uma ignorância é hoje existem várias
várias pós-graduações que seu make
faculdade para quem já se formou e hoje
também infelizmente é existem escolas
que não aceitam as pessoas têm
deficiência intelectual e o que é
deficiente intelectual
há pessoas que têm deficiência
intelectual aquela pessoa que tem
dificuldade para realizar as tarefas do
dia a dia
a maior barreira de dificuldades das
pessoas que têm deficiência intelectual
é a auto suficiência que como eu acabei
de dizer às realizas tarefas do
dia-a-dia medo nossa vida pessoal na sua
vida profissional
na sua vida familiar e com os amigos ou
seja pela vejo sempre de bem com a vida
a inclusão de todos sempre
após a transação pode mandar o mercado
de trabalho
gre mercado de trabalho grandes chefes
executivos artesãos estilistas e
esportistas e é claro que muitas mas
muitas profissões
todos nós somos vencedores
as pessoas que têm deficiência
intelectual aprendendo com a gente ea
gente aprendendo com ele sempre todos
nós o supermando grande shines a
tecnologia ajudou demais
por exemplo a pessoa que tem deficiência
física pode a é com a tecnologia uma
perna mecânica uma cadeira de rodas e aí
eu pensei quando eu posso contribuir se
eu não sei fazer a tecnologia sozinha eu
e aqui no porto já teve uma época que
teve é que quando você pega uma latinha
de sucos e refrigerantes
você tira o lacre e você pode botar um
saque em um incidente e quando juntarem
acho que 300 garrafinhas de pet mesmo é
essa
vocês podem mandar para uma thurman
acho que a fábrica que faz cadeiras de
rodas e eles podem formar é criar uma
cadeira de rodas
uns têm os pequenos lábios então eu
parei para pensar eu posso fazer o
mínimo esforço para salvar até a vida de
alguém
as empresas estão estão começando a se
conscientizarem adaptando os lugares de
trabalho para todos
você conhece ou é alguma pessoa querida
deficiência intelectual não se sinta
diferente porque somos todos iguais
coloca como eu já disse tudo isso por um
futuro mais colorido e você já feita com
atos de bondade ou gentileza como nós
estamos estudando nicolau me dar um
beijo
obrigada e espero que vocês também
contribui